Andrew Doyle welcome to trigonometry
hello hello and welcome to trigonometry
I'm Frances Foster I'm Constance and
kissing and this is the show for you if
you were bored of people arguing with
each other on the internet over subjects
they know nothing about a trigonometry
we don't pretend to be experts we ask
the experts
we're here the world-famous angel comedy
club and our amazing guests this week is
a stand-up comedian columnist for Spike
magazine and co-writer for Jonathan pie
Andrew Doyle
welcome to trigonometry hello
so so entry tell us a little bit about
how you came to be sitting on that chair
because you asked me and what I just do
anything well you've had a great career
already who have you come to the point
that you're at you were a comedian first
yeah well I mean I started out writing
plays and sketches and this kind of
thing and I was also a teacher at the
time and then one night we did a sketch
show it was now along with a couple of
friends and we had a sort of 10-minute
deficit so I said I will just write I'll
try a bit a stand-up and I did it I mean
it wasn't very good to be honest but I
enjoyed it and then I sort of went into
it that way and then that became my sort
of main source of income so I went
part-time as a teacher and then left
teaching and then this is why I dunno
how did you get to writing for spiked
and then working with Jonathan PI oh so
those are two very different areas of my
life but the spiked thing came about
because I had met a couple of the people
who are involved with spiked and the
deputy editor Tom Slater got me to write
one or two things because I agree very
much with their stance on free speech so
I wrote a couple of things and I became
very conscious and I was aware of how
unpopular spiked is amongst the comedy
circuit and there's a kind of stigma
attached to the publication based
typically on on a lack of knowledge
about what the publication is to be fair
so I was a bit hesitant a bit cowardly
about it actually and I thought well I'm
not gonna make this a regular thing and
then a couple of years ago about two and
a three years ago I got to the point in
my life where I thought you know I'm
gonna stop just being a mealy-mouthed
about what I think I'm gonna start
saying what I actually think because I
think honesty is really important it's
quite self-destructive not to be honest
and also it's about respecting other
people enough to be honest to them and
know that they're not going to shun you
for that so I just started writing what
I thought for spiked on a regular basis
so I became a columnist for them and
it's been really great I think but some
people don't share that view for the
benefit of our viewers and listeners who
may not have been Scout encountered
spike Magazine could you describe it a
little bit what it is for them yeah it's
a radical humanist
magazine it has his origins in Marxism
its
I suppose on the left but it's
libertarian which some people see as a
contradiction but actually it is
compatible it's very much got its got it
I mean a lot of the authors disagree
with each other on various points but
there are some broad editorial lines as
all publications do I'd say it's it's
very consistently anti Trump anti new
labor anti conservative it's very anti
racism Pro human rights it believes in
unlimited immigration no borders
whatsoever these are the sort of central
premises it also has an editorial line
where it has a certain skepticism about
climate change which I don't share but
on the whole it's also predominantly a
free speech magazine so and that to me
is one of the most important things and
the most important topics that we're
facing at the moment so I agree with
more than I disagree and that's why I
write for it fantastic and you said that
these free speech is a very important
topic at the moment what do you think
it's become more important now as
opposed to five years ago just to make
an arbitrary I'd say something has
happened over the past five ten years
and we have this kind of creeping
authoritarianism that's occurring in a
country or in the West generally and it
I think it's come out of a kind of
misunderstanding a misapplication of
political correctness but political
correctness was from my era you know
it's from the sort of 90s this idea that
we should have a kind of shared
discourse a shared understanding of the
way in which it is polite to interact
with other people in the public space in
the workplace all of this kind of thing
which I'm very much on board with and I
think that's just a good idea not to
criminalize the way that the people
speak but to sort and have a sort of
shared understanding and as a society
encourage and dis encourage that certain
things I don't have a product that's a
really good thing I think that's sort of
morphed into something new what's
happening now I wouldn't call political
correctness I don't think that's what
this is I think it's something else and
I haven't really decided what it should
be called and I'm not in a position to
make that judgment but it's not really
political correctness it's a new kind of
identity politics which is very much
focused on intersectional grievances and
the idea of victimhood as currency and I
think it's very very damaging an
extremely divisive and I think it
something that needs to be resisted it's
also
a means by which censorship can be
called for from a position of virtue and
that troubles me deeply because all of
the civil rights movements all of the
movement from the new left in the in the
60s and 70s in terms of gay rights in
terms of feminism in terms of civil
rights for racial minorities all had at
their heart a belief that free speech
was essential because if you don't have
free speech none of those other rights
will follow now we have a situation
where people are prepared particular on
the left or that what I prefer to call
the liberal left to sacrifice the
fundamental principles of democracy in
the fundamental principles of free
speech for something that is perceived
to be a greater good which is what which
is the protection of vulnerable groups I
find this to be not only damaging to
vulnerable groups but it's a it's a
surefire way to generate resentment and
divide society more and more and more
and we see what happens we see what
happens Donald Trump is in the White
House I can't think that I mean he ran
his campaign on the basis of being anti
what he calls PE see you know it's it's
a kind of frustration that you see
amongst huge sways of the population
that they are continue with their poor
they've got nothing they've got no hope
they've ever since the Third Way and the
Clintons and the Blair's they've had
nothing at all and all of a sudden
they're voting for any kind of changes
gonna explode the system they just want
to change it and they're told while
they're struggling and they have nothing
that they're privileged and that they
they are racist when a lot of them are
not racist majority of them are not race
they're told they're homophobic they're
told they're sexist and they're
continually battered in this way and it
generates an awful lot of resentment and
then it backfires so what I say to the
proponents on the liberal left who
pushed this kind of agenda is you if
this is self-defeating you were
destroying yourselves I'm coming from
the left so I'm saying we need to do
better than this because if we don't
then the problem is going to perpetuate
but you see somebody would then go well
actually what you're you're saying this
in your you know you in a very
comfortable career you are a man of
privilege or a white man of course you
would say these things because you've
never been oppressed there's a huge
amount of assumptions in that statement
yes yeah I see that I have a successful
career
[Laughter]
if I did have a successful career I
wouldn't be struggling for money all the
time often the accusation of privilege
comes with all kinds of assumptions and
what I've noticed is that people who
peddle this idea tend to be from very
upper-middle class backgrounds it seems
to be a very bourgeois concern identity
politics at the moment I'm not saying in
all cases but certainly the most
prominent vocal elements of the liberal
left double-barrelled names tend to I
mean they're the books that are being
published about this stuff where people
are desperate for victimhood tend to be
quite well-off people who people who
talk about their holidays in the
Pyrenees when they were young and and
all of this kind of stuff so I don't
know where the assumption that I'm
privileged is privileged for me of
course
people face homophobia and racism and
all this stuff and we need to stand up
against that but above all else what
privilege comes from money from contacts
from opportunity from nepotism from all
of the stuff that middle-class people
have only 7% of this country are
educated to private schools but they're
disproportionately represented in the
law in the media in journalism in all of
the major in politics all of the major
positions so really if we wanted to just
to sort this out societally we would
address that imbalance so I would never
say to someone you're privileged because
you were white it doesn't make any it
doesn't make any sense I mean when
Monroe bergdorf the labor activist said
that you can still be homeless and have
white privilege that is incredibly
insulting thing to say from someone who
is so privileged so upper middle class
and has had all these benefits but as an
ethnic minority and trans person all of
a sudden the the the victim hierarchy
shifts and so someone who's homeless is
suddenly more is privileged or
potentially privileged I mean this is a
nonsense so I think we have to think in
terms of class I think if you're not
thinking in terms of class consciousness
you can't really high self identifies
left in my view or there were a lot of
people on the Left do seem to think that
by by focusing solely and I must
emphasize I'm not saying that tackling
racism and homophobia sexism isn't
important it's key to what I believe in
what I'm saying is it is often done at
the expense of class concerns now there
was it would be one thing if it was if
we were covering everything but that
doesn't appear to be asserting my
reading of it that is not how how things
are playing out in a practical sense so
if you say to me well my argument is
is undermined by the fact that I'm white
well or the fact that I'm male how do we
know that I haven't been disadvantaged
in in other ways how do you know I mean
you don't curious about that because we
were talking about just before we
started actually and I I asked you if
you're gay because I read that you did a
show oh the way you talked partly about
that and I'm curious that you haven't
brought that up in defense of your right
to speak which I find interesting
because that is the instinct we most of
us now have isn't it
to kind of go where I'm oppressed as
well then I think I think it would be
irrelevant if I were a black gay female
I I think the argument is what matter I
think this okay so this is where I think
a lot of the liberal left are going
wrong it's that they've forgotten how to
argue we don't have critical thinking at
the heart of schooling anymore I used to
teach critical thinking at a level it's
really really key and it's important the
first thing you learn from a critical
thinking course is as soon as you attack
the person or not the argument you've
lost it's an ad hominem attack so anyone
who in invokes your race your gender
your sexuality has already lost the
argument it's not an adequate
argumentative technique so that to me is
something we need to get back to you
need to address the point okay so let me
give you for instance so if you say to
me if I make a point make an argument
about identity politics and you say well
I don't accept that argument because
you're white and you're male right what
happens then when I introduce you to a
woman a black woman who is making an
identical point so is the point sudden
is the argument suddenly more persuasive
is that what you're telling me now this
is the prom with people who peddle
identity politics in its current form
they are undermining themselves because
if your rebuttal depends on something
that is individual about the person
you're arguing then when you when you
are faced with the identical argument
from someone who doesn't fit that
demographic you have nowhere else to go
and you what they do have somewhere else
to go actually because what they do then
is they call that person a race traitor
or a traitor to the gender or the
internalized misogyny right self-hating
then a woman saying to another woman
well you're not thinking in the right
way I mean that is underpinned by a
genuine misogyny all your suffering of
all your an Uncle Tom were yours or your
self-hating I mean how dare someone make
that assumption about someone maybe
someone just disagrees with you maybe
that's okay right it's interesting for
me because
I'm from Russia that's where I was I was
born in the Soviet Union but I'm from
Russia and people said to me what in
these kind of situations well you're
white you don't know we're talking about
if interestingly someone who looks like
me in Russia I had people in Russia come
up to me in the street and say in
Russian literally you are black go home
Wow because people who look like me in
Russia are the discriminated against
minority okay but no one in the UK could
possibly know that without having a
conversation with me first quite so
they've made innocent you've made an
assumption based on their experience as
opposed to anything about my experience
whatsoever so now that my oppression
credentials are firmly establish yeah
it's a shame isn't it that we feel we
have to we have to do that that we have
to establish those yes it doesn't make
any sense
it respective who makes them surely it's
currently going on in the Internet is I
think it's quite selfish because I think
a lot of these people do it not because
they're actually interested in
supporting or progressing the rights of
ethnic minorities or gay people disabled
or trans or whatever it may be I think
they do it from a purely selfish point
of view whereby they do it to
essentially propel their own careers and
make a name for themselves the trouble
with that I mean that could potentially
be true the trouble I would have with
that is I'm very wary of ever trying to
intuit motive on behalf of the person
I'm arguing against it yeah it's far
better to just address the arguments as
they are presented rather than it
because otherwise you're more reasonable
than my underlying kind of because we
know don't we that now victimhood has
power attached which is an odd paradox
isn't it but the more of a victim you
can present yourself as the more what
the more currency you'll have now we and
this political clout behind being a
victim and we know that now but the
problem is if you and if I assume that
someone is not telling the truth out of
a desire for personal gain then again I
am as guilty of the thing I've just
accused other people of which is I'm not
addressing the argument and also you can
defeat the argument irrespective of
motive
so it doesn't matter what their motive
is actually if you've defeated the
argument then job done so whether that
whether their motive is malevolent or
benevolent it does it doesn't matter you
still won the argument so that would be
my
my suggestion in that in that case
people often impute motive to me all the
time so I make these sorts of arguments
and it's and it's because I'm I'm a
self-hating gay man or it's because i'm
a racist i'm all right all of this kind
of thing because otherwise they have to
deal with the arguments I'm actually
making so it's much easier to keep
mischaracterize your opponent and enter
into a kind of straw man debate it's
much easier people are very hesitant to
address what's actually being said it's
a big problem do you think that actually
social media has just exacerbated the
situation because now people on social
media because they've got literally a
computer screen in front of them yeah
and between their opponent they suddenly
feel emboldened to say whatever it is
they want and to make horrible claims
and say horrible things to people that
they would never dream of saying it
face-to-face yeah it's terrible isn't it
the anonymity of the of the online
experience of course you have this kind
of yeah I mean I've had it a recent I
was being I suppose you call it trolling
I've been trolled by a group of them and
arca communists American or coke 4 means
cocaine it sounds like a contradiction
in terms if you're in an art if you're
an anarchist you don't believe in the
state at all if you're communist you
believe that the state should run
everything yeah but actually it's a kind
of they don't believe in the state at
all they want to abolish the stay inside
they don't believe in the wage labor the
idea of employment or that kind of thing
and we're all comedians we don't believe
in employment either no there we go so
I'd say sorry and they and they're very
much you know when you get involved in
debates with people like this that they
are incapable of argument they're there
their entire belief system seems to be
based on faith it's not not to do with
them they can't rationalize but when
you're being a sort of troll on the
internet it even if it's only a handful
like five or six people it feels like
the whole world is against you it's a
but I've got I've got used to it now
because a particular a couple of the
Jonathan PI videos I've had a lot of
that kind of thing I've got I've got
used to and and I don't take it too
seriously now and I just I just ignore
it but like you say social media has
exacerbated the problem hugely and I
think it's because these minority voices
that aren't really very rational that
haven't read very much don't really know
very much are suddenly amplified and
they have this kind of power
and that leads to a kind of polarization
of politics and we can see it can't we
we can see it's manifested itself in
terms of national politics as well
hasn't it in terms of the the rise of
parties that are further to the right
than ever before we've seen all over
Europe in France in Italy here to a
degree we've seen and the rise of maybe
the more kind of leftist korbinite style
of politics as well so it works in both
ways and that that worries me as well as
that but you're either one thing or the
other
and particularly the debates that I see
online it's very much well you've
disagreed with me on this slight point
so therefore I'm lumbering you in the
the other extreme which is very very
very dangerous I mean the example I
would give is that because I write for
spiked and because a lot of people don't
read spike and don't really understand
where it's coming from it's easy to just
say well spike is an old right
publication now all right means in
common parlance means white nationalists
it irrevocably connected to white
nationalists so how can a publication
that has been consistently anti-racist
for its entire existence that criticizes
the alt-right explicitly again and again
and again be alright it can only be if
you don't understand what all tripe
means or if you're being dishonest about
about that about that imputation
coming back to freedom of speech yeah we
kind of got into a little bit of why
it's so important and I you touched on
the fact that freedom of speech is
essentially a guarantee of all our other
rights and opportunities and I I wonder
how you can communicate that to people
in the West now particularly younger
people because you know I grew up in my
first probably 1213 years I spent in the
Soviet Union struck Russia yeah and I
grew up with tales of my grandmother
telling me about how she was born in the
concentration camp yeah and a Soviet
gulag for political prisoners yes and
the reason that she was born in the
Soviet concentration camp is that her
dad had meetings where they discussed
fringe elements of politics yeah and
this was reported to the authorities he
was sent to the GU like his wife much
the same and they spent 15 years each in
hard labor camps yeah and in this camp
in in in in my great-grandfather's camp
every morning the whole population the
camp would be led out onto the shore
onto the ice of the lake this was in
Siberia three people would be taken at
random and thrown in the icy rivers in
nicely waters of that lake and killed in
front of everybody yeah to remind
everybody what happens if you speak out
of turn if you don't follow the rules of
Session this was the price that people
paid for speaking their mind yeah now I
don't think anyone in the West now has
any conception of what that's like yeah
we have no physical in connection to
that kind of experience we don't have
grandmother's telling us that so how do
we explain to people people who are
really reading or listening or watching
or whatever yeah
the that is kind of what happens when
you don't have free speech it's it's a
path down towards that it's difficult
because free speech is something that
needs to be fought for in every new
generation it's something that needs to
be maintained and I've got to see what
you're describing it's such a horrific
unimaginable experience that we can't
share we don't have anything that comes
close to that I think a lot of the
problem is that people of my generation
and younger haven't experienced war or
anything like this we haven't had
anything like that so we take these
freedoms for granted whereas actually we
do need to guard against this sort of
stuff and comparatively the free speech
fights that are going on at the moment
in this country and in America pale in
- something like that of course they do
so it's very easy to say well this
doesn't really matter but of course
these things work in an inch meal way
don't like it's one thing and then it's
the next and these things gradually
build and build and we've actually seen
it in our country I mean now we have a
situation where people are routinely
jailed for things they say right now you
might say well it doesn't matter is just
a few working-class teenagers making
jokes about Madeleine McCann on Facebook
they're not very nice jokes so it
doesn't matter right well that's the
first step right and what happens next
these these the law works in precedence
so then you get more and more people who
are who are at risk of this kind of
legislation and at least I know a bit
about history I know where this stuff
leads it starts in increments so you
have to battle it from the from the be
kind of wait until it's gone too far
and I know that sounds alarmist and I'm
not suggesting we're gonna end up with a
tyrannical government that's going to
shoot every third person or something
like that I'm not I'm not suggesting
that but I am suggesting it's a
possibility and I'm suggesting that that
history teaches us this that individual
liberties is is worth preserving it's an
interesting point you raised I mean how
much do you think I mean we'll just
touch on Corbin my mother's from
Venezuela and I don't know if you know
what's going on in Venezuela
yeah but we're pretty much go in the
same way Soviet Russia depressingly if
you are seen to be talking or
criticizing the government there'll be a
knock on the door and you will disappear
yeah it's that's literally where men in
ski masks we're less classy I find it
very very worrying that Corbin has
supported its supports of Venezuelan
government and does not offer a direct
criticism of them yeah do you find that
worrying because I say to people on the
far left and I get slammed down as being
alright yeah but again that that that
feeds back into what I was talking about
that if you don't fully agree then you
must be part of the other faction and
not only that the most extreme version
of the other other function I have
reservations as well about some of copán
sympathies I did vote for Corbin as it
happens but I think all three of us did
actually how did we selection yet right
for labor anyway yeah so I do have
reservation there's no doubt that what's
happening Venezuela it's going to seed
you know and then and sometimes you you
have to be able to say I
agree broadly with many of his points
but actually he's getting this wrong and
there's various things that he is
getting wrong I think and we have to be
able to talk about that but I think
we're in a situation where it is that I
either you are on Corbin side or you're
not and that's not how politics works
because people are complex individuals
with many many different views and you
have to be able to debate each
perspective I suppose the
counter-arguments what you're saying
about freedom of speech is where do you
draw the line is it alright to use
racial slurs for instance is it alright
for an Islamic preacher to say to go on
a box in somewhere then I bet them green
for example and talk and say that
Western civilization is an evil is evil
and that it should be wiped from the
surface of the earth because surely
isn't he exercising his freedom his
right to freedom of speech yeah and my
instinct would be that he should be
allowed to do that I am obviously I'm
not happy when I hear a preacher I mean
I've had it I've walked through this
isn't playing a victim card again is now
I walk believes it you send a someone
was shouting about homosexuals yeah how
they all should be criminalized and all
the rest of it but you see and and of
course a preacher calling for the
destruction of the West right yeah okay
so these are not pleasant things racial
slurs definitely not pleasant things
none of us support it but I think the
price you pay for living in a free
society is that some people are gonna
say unpleasant things right and I think
on balance that is the preferable
scenario also I'm troubled by the idea
that we will reach a point legislatively
where racists and evil people are unable
to out themselves as such I'd rather
know who they were I'd rather know where
they are and I'd rather they were
expressing themselves because that way
we can combat it otherwise what you do
is you drive it underground you don't
ever defeat an argument by censoring it
anyone who knows anything about the
history of censorship knows this often
you draw more attention to it
in fact you give them a power you give
up it's called the Streisand effect you
you give it a lot of power we've had it
this week the BBC Radio 4 are going to
broadcast a full transcript of Enoch
Powell Rivers of Blood speech now this
was going out to a radio for audience no
one would have noticed no one would have
cared right I'm not saying there are
people listed ready for I've written for
ready for light ready for but look let's
face it these people aren't going to go
out and
but because of the complaints and the
the Twitter storm that's happened today
everyone's gonna listen right you have
just drawn attention to the very thing
that you would you're not happy about
that's that's all that's happened there
so I would say in terms of free speech
we already have laws about harassment
you know if you if you are harassing
someone or labelling someone I mean
there are debates about whether our
libel laws are too strange and I suspect
they probably are but we have those laws
in place I don't think that it's
sensible to curtail speech out of fear
that it might influence our people in a
bad way because what you're doing then
is you're you're allowing the
perpetrators of crimes to not have
responsibility for their own actions
which I don't think is right so I'm
actually very skeptical about the
concept of hate speech full-stop because
if somebody calls for you to go out and
beat up game in and then somebody does
that the responsibility must lie with
the person who did it
not with the person who said it so you
actually think people should be in sight
should be able allowed to incite
violence I think it's a really difficult
question mm-hmm I think on balance I
think probably I don't want to see
anyone criminalized for what they say or
what they think I think it's true it
seems like it doesn't it wouldn't go
quite that way for me the cutoff is
definitely the incitement to violence if
you're calling for other people to
commit actually which I illegal yes then
that shouldn't be allowed in my opinion
yeah you would go further than that I
think I would and just because I think
we have to get back to the idea of
individual responsibility I also don't
believe that people are these mindless
drones that are just going to be
influenced in this way I have a much
greater faith in humanity than that I
think we have autonomy I do I am
uncomfortable with anyone calling for
violence I'm very uncomfortable with it
I I despise it and I think protest
ridicule these these are the weapons to
use against people like that as you as
soon as you shut them up lock them away
you give them this odd kind of martyrdom
that they don't deserve you give them
this glamour you end up propagating the
ideas that they're attempting to spread
so that's why I'm you know I'm I'm
willing to be persuaded differently my
instinct would be to never police people
for what they say or what they
well let's talk about you mentioned hate
speech let's talk about a couple of
incidents that have happened in the UK
recently and you know the countdown
killer thing for example he's been
talking to death and we don't want to
really spend too much time on the guy
himself but there are some implications
that came out of that core case
particularly which I think a hugely
relevant to society do you want to tell
her Tildy listeners and viewers first of
all what actually happened briefly and
then yep very briefly because it has
been covered as yet very briefly a man
in Scotland called Marcus Meakin created
a YouTube video where he taught his
girlfriend's hug to perform a Nazi
salute and to react in an excited way to
the phrases gas the Jews and Zeke Heil
and there's even as a moment where the
dog is watching an insert from Hitler's
speeches etc so that's the Jack really
trying not to laugh because the video it
is unquestionably funny if you love your
fascist I mean all of it my Jewish grant
for great-grandfather died fighting this
I'm allowed to laugh very interested we
did we I mean I run a comedy night every
month in London we played the video last
week and we actually prefaced it the
host prefaced it by saying you know this
probably isn't very funny I mean he
didn't think it was funny he said I'm
not gonna tell you what to think and
then we played it and the audience
laughed a lot so many Nazis I know it's
very fair with a Jewish host as well as
very interesting but um it's a it's a
bug and I think whenever this argument
ends up gonna have to keep in mind is a
bug
okay now people who haven't seen the
video okay well will tell you that it's
the repetition of the phrase gas the
Jews it's a horrible phrase that's the
joke because it's a cute bug and the
joke is that is using this really really
ghastly phrase that any any one would
find inexcusable but that is the joke
okay
so whether you find it funny or not or
whether you find it offensive or not is
beside the point
no one no one with with a reasonable IQ
could ever confer could ever deny that
the intention was to be funny now what
is what is troubling about this
particular ruling and I don't wanna get
into the debates of whether it's funny
or not or whether it's relevant isn't it
is a rather completely irrelevant about
defending free speeches you have to
defend it when people are saying things
you don't like exactly otherwise it's
not free speech the prosecution's
contention in this case
is that he is using humor as a guise to
disseminate anti-semitic hatred he's
using a pug can we just remember that
pug to keep saying that okay and they
are the stupidest of all the dogs well
there we go I wouldn't know about that
but if you are serious about propagating
Nazism you're not going to use a pug
you're just not first sugaring moment of
this podcast is well and truly done it
is an important point I think that this
this particular case is a new benchmark
as I've said there's lots and lots of
cases where the Communications Act has
been used to crimp to to jail people for
making jokes it happens all the time but
we don't hear about it so many people
are prosecuted and investigated all the
time and there has been jail time served
we don't really hear about it this case
is a bit more significant firstly
because the ax man in question self
identifies as a comedian again there's
all debates Mabel I don't think he's a
comedian is irrelevant but it's easy
he's put up a comedic video so that's
the first thing
secondly the court has said explicitly
that intention and context do not apply
and do not matter well if that is the
case then anyone making a joke could be
in trouble
okay so you say that again because I
think people don't quite understand the
whole meaning of that yeah the context
and intention do not matter court decide
their Court said they decide the context
they do not believe his intention they
decide the context it doesn't matter
it's the repetition of that phrase now
bear in mind that this video went viral
there were three million views not one
complaint because people aren't stupid
and they got what it was okay and then
then comes the ahkamaat well this is
offensive to Jewish people or who gets
to decide that because there's an awful
lot of Jewish people who found it funny
right so there's that not one complaint
the police took it upon themselves to
investigate this and what they did is
they actively sought people out who
might be offended so they approached the
Scottish counsel the Jewish communities
and said what do you think and then what
happens is of course they say I find it
offensive well that's their right yeah
yeah I find things things offensive you
know that's their right to find that
offensive and to be upset by it okay but
it's not the state's right to then
imprison someone for their
once the the man from the the council
tester from the Scottish council Jewish
communities testified in court then you
have these awful people online sending
him anti-semitic messages and abuse
which is a terrible thing to happen
right
but then the media retrospectively
pretend that those messages came out
people incited by the video didn't
happen but it came out with the
testimony I'm not I'm not in any way
defending the abuse but let's get the
story right people aren't watching this
this poke video and going out and think
of right I'm gonna want to attack Jewish
people that isn't it's never happened
and it wouldn't happen so it's it is
very very troubling but this is the
point I'm making about hate speech and
why are they so dangerous it was all
very will you saying an imam standing up
and calling for the deaths of
homosexuals it's a pretty clear-cut this
is a nasty horrible guy now look I don't
want to live in a society where that
person exists or says what he says but
I'd rather live in that society than a
society where people can be thrown in
prison for what they say and that's why
I make that at that point okay and I
know that some of you're uncomfortable
you might be uncomfortable with that but
that's my broader point which I'm
willing to be persuaded out of if you
can convince me but in this case the
court decided that the rapid the
repetition of the phrase gas the Jews
without context without intent is
tantamount to hate speech and incitement
to violence that that was their
conclusion right so what we have here is
a kind of concept creep right and this
is why I'm also troubled by hate speech
because what if okay if you have that
sort of case where we could say okay
that that man is obviously hateful and
awful and we put that under the bracket
of hate speech who then decides who then
decides that me making a joke isn't hate
speech as well because the parameters
are constantly shifting because the the
window is constantly getting bigger and
bigger then there comes a point where
we're all potentially within that window
and that's why it's probably better on
balance to not have hate speech hate
speech legislation at all because the
potential for abuse is too great the
police
the Metropolitan Police have a guideline
which you can check online about what
hate speech is and their definition of
hate speech is that irrespective of the
intent of the person so long as someone
deems something to have been offensive
and also perceives that the person did
it out of prejudice or hatred for their
sexuality race or gender that is enough
to qualify as hate speech so even if
even if the person did not mean that
even if it was unintentional it can
still be a crime so it is so nebulous
that nobody in a free society is safe
under that legislation
okay now I'm willing to have the debate
about well someone calling explicitly
for violence that would be one thing but
I'm not confident that the state or the
people in power or the police understand
the difference between someone calling
for violence explicitly and someone
making a joke on Facebook well that's
interesting thing because I was
discussing this issue this incident with
can't ankle or with comedians are the
comedian's on Facebook and different
things and there were a lot of people I
found who were very happy to defend the
court's decision yeah lots and their
argument would seem to be well first of
all I didn't like the joke which as you
say in relevant yeah but the other thing
is one incident in particular just blew
my mind I was talking to somebody and
they said well the thing is I don't
think he should have gone to prison he
just needed to get a clip around the ear
old-school style and just teach him a
lesson and I said well you are now
inciting violence
sarcastically yeah right and they said
well context matters and I said well
that's the whole point the core rule the
context doesn't matter yeah you know and
he will seem to miss this point entirely
if context doesn't matter than even us
discussing I've quoted the phrase he
used a number of times right if context
doesn't matter then I've just incited
anti-semitic hatred I just like to
publicly disassociate myself from
anything that happens but yes you're
right it's I'm I'm fully understanding
of comedians who don't want to ally
themselves with this guy I understand
I'm not saying that if you don't I
understand in the Johnathan pie video we
wrote about this we have a line where
it's like where are the comedians right
but that's a character delivering that
line yeah I'm not saying comedians have
an obligation just honor for anyone or
anything right that's an individual
matter but when somebody sides with the
court actively signs of estate
authoritarianism I have a problem with
that and and I'm going to argue against
that I think that's I think that's
really dangerous and it's self-defeating
and I can't believe people can't see it
one of the interesting things for me as
well is this notion and not just in a
can thank you thing but brought more
broadly in society there is this idea
somehow that
words can be violence words yeah are
violence sometimes so people talk about
the fact that it's like a force
continuum almost like first of all you
call me a derogatory name yeah and if
that's okay then you do something else
and if that's okay then you're gonna
punch me in the street yeah no how do
you what what are your thoughts about we
have to be able to separate words and
violence I mean we grew up we all grew
up with the phrase sticks and stones may
break my bones but names will never hurt
me
now we believe the opposite why nobody
is denying that words can cause
psychological harm some of the most
distressing experiences of my life have
been from things that people have said
not things people have done so nobody
denies that okay
but there has to be a distinction
between words and violence because when
you are upset by words it is something
that you have emotionally done do you
know it's a way that you have
interpreted something okay
physical attack is a different level
isn't it is that certain words some
people use racial slurs yeah they do
cause damage and they almost a form of
violence could you not agree like if you
know what hit you on the head yeah
they're damaging your brain yeah if
someone says something nasty I'm not I
don't agree with this argument at all
but if you call an Asian person a [ __ ]
that means that that there is a form of
violence is it not that is you trying to
intimidate them yes you trying to upset
them that's you trying to engender in
them a negative reaction you're trying
to hurt them what you've just
experienced yeah not violence I don't I
don't see them is the same I think it's
a failure of socialization as well I
mean I I believe in adult autonomy 100%
but I believe at schools we need to we
need to have the debate about how
children are socialized what terms are
then we need to be able to register
objections to certain terminology and so
and the ways in which we express
ourselves and just treating people with
respect that you know what you were
describing someone who has not been
successfully socialized I would say but
I think we have to draw those
distinctions I think we do because for
one thing it's often used as a pretext
to justify
preemptive violence so can Tifa yes yes
a good example so they will say words
are violence so that justifies us pepper
spraying a trump supporter has happened
in Berkeley I think vote in many other
places it justifies us kicking down the
doors and charging into somebody's
meeting or someone's peaceful discussion
event right it justifies the violence
then that's dangerous so that's why I
think we have to have whilst we have an
acknowledgment that words hurt and can't
an app and that we should be encouraging
as a society responsibility in the way
that we express ourselves and how we
express ourselves and and calling for
empathy and all of the rest of it really
important but again the dangers the
implications of conflating words of
words and violence are too dangerous to
contemplate and therefore we have to be
able to make the distinction well one
interesting thing that just occurred to
me in relation to what you said Francis
is that actually you don't need to use
derogatory terms to hurt someone's
feelings
not really you could insult someone or
have really heard them psychologically
by using perfectly normal language yes
would that's not insulting in and of
itself but you are you you are
diminishing their status or whatever is
that you're doing you couldn't sell
someone and heard them just by speaking
normal words but in many ways those
words are a shortcut yeah so for
instance you know use a racial slur
against a black person you know that is
a word that we all know that has been
used as a derogatory term for Generation
Y a comes from horrific oppression yeah
and immediately it's a shortcut for you
to say to them you are inferior to me
right so we it has baggage language has
baggage and it has implications and no
no but I don't think anybody's is
denying that and so it is difficult but
I think your argument though is based on
this utopian idea that if we police
people's language and the words that we
are and are not allowed to say suddenly
we will fix society and all of the
people who have these instincts that are
unpleasant will disappear but it won't
happen it won't happen and I I think I'm
more comfortable you know I don't like
when people use horrible words against
me as they as they have done many times
it's a horrible experience is really
unpleasant I'm quite a sensitive person
in spite of the fact I probably don't
seem that way but
you know in a sense that is a part of
life that human beings are complex
creatures and some of us are not going
to be particularly pleasant creatures
you learn who to avoid you learn how to
get out of certain situations I just
think the implications of criminalizing
speech are so vast that and I'm not
saying we tolerate these pits or people
who use this kind of language you
challenge them or you reject them or you
don't you don't associate with them all
of the rest of you they become pariahs
thankfully I think that is the case I
mean I think if you start going on
Twitter and using racial slurs you're
not gonna get a job anywhere anytime
soon that you you will be a pariah we
live in a society where we work that is
the case it's it's become the case would
you not agree with that I think we are
definitely know that I don't know
anybody I doubt I could literally not
name anybody that I've ever encountered
on a personal level who thinks that
calling a racial minority I turned like
that is acceptable I don't I wouldn't
associate with that sort of person it's
something I think racism is just
unforgivable I couldn't I couldn't be a
friend or even own acquaintance with
someone who had those instincts but it's
an also part of that and that you live
in this sort of again I'm going to use
terms but lefty liberal bubble in London
you know where all your friends you know
again I'm generalize with you I agree
with that yeah I mean partly because of
my family background that I know people
more like my family had not from this
London Metropolitan elite and I'm not
saying that gives me license or whatever
but I'm just saying that my experience
of people is perhaps a bit more broad
than you assume yeah but even if it even
if it wasn't I hope my opinion I think
would be the same
so we were talking we've been talking
about a lot recently you've recently
released a video well Jonathan pie has
are what you're talking about the gender
pay gap and it called widespread outrage
I think is the right word to use I mean
incensed on who I mean if it followed
off the back of the video we did about
the Nazi Pogue yeah which I think
probably caused more outrage it was
unfortunate because we'd written the
video a few weeks before that it just so
happened that the Polk thing happened
and then we had to release this at this
time cuz it was ready to go
and it looked like we were being
deliberately provocative doing two
consecutive pieces like that but that
was the narrative actually husband isn't
it like you've gone alright like Jonna
pie is gone alright sure yeah he's
actually been criticizing the left for
ages I mean hasn't he you both I mean
you have absolutely I mean if you're
familiar with the back catalogue
Jonathan pie is a lefty who bashes the
Tories more than anyone else
the Tories and Trump more than anyone
else so I mean if you you're gonna pick
out these few videos where he's I mean
he does attack the left for where the
left is going wrong because he cares
about where the left is going wrong so
that makes sense to me but the trouble
is I suppose that the videos that cause
contention are the ones that people
remember or know about and maybe they
don't watch all all of the other ones
and they don't get that perspective
perhaps so on the gender pay gap he made
a video where Jonathan PI interviews
what he thinks is a feminist academic
yeah who's releasing a book and he's
asking her expecting her to provide the
usual narrative about the gender pay gap
right and what he encounters and very
quickly gets frustrated by is that she's
more of a second wave feminist and a
third way feminist she's not into the
whole victimhood thing that's now so
popular which is what you've been
talking about right so it's a satire in
the media as well the media have an
expectation of a certain narrative that
they have to produce and then when
they're confronted with something
they're not familiar with they don't
know what to do so it's a satirical
piece yeah and what was the response to
that okay so some people weren't I sort
of stayed out of this one quite a bit
when when the when people started
attacking us on Twitter but yes there
was a bit of a backlash
from certain feminist groups and from
certain feminist figures and comedians
more than anything I mean I didn't get
involved but I I am aware of lots of
threads that appeared on Facebook in
which I was described as an all-right
anti-feminist all the rest of it because
friends might keep sending me
screenshots look what these people are
saying about you and it's and it's skate
out frenzy yeah it's odd it's odd that a
four star piece of fiction a piece of
satire can generate that kind of
response but it's also I'm up for the
debate you know if anyone wants to email
me and say why I'm wrong great and we'll
talk about it you know I'm and also what
was very interesting on all these
threads I saw all these arguments not
once did anyone present a coherent
counter-argument to any argument was
made in the video not once
it was just ad hominem it was just
you're right you're anti-feminist well
I'm not and I always called myself a
feminist always have I worry now that to
use the word means that because the word
is so currently being used to describe a
kind of victim-centered feminism
whereas I believe feminism is about
equality and empowerment and unfortunate
that makes me an old-fashioned kind of
feminist but on the other hand I
shouldn't allow people to misappropriate
the word so in a sense I should hold on
to it but so that's what we were that
were in the character in that video is
as you say a feminist who hates the fact
for instance that the BBC have promoted
an app for your phone that will help
women to speak up in meetings and we
make the point that this is horribly
patronizing I mean some of my female
friends found this the most disgusting
thing but it's hailed as the BBC is this
really progressive wonderful thing I
would say the victim centered feminism
although the people who promote it or
not of course misogynists but the
premise of it is misogynist the premise
of it is that women are weaker and need
extra protection and that's why I don't
agree with it it's interesting because
some of the episodes will be releasing
probably after this one we've talked to
several very accomplished women who have
been political advisors or economists or
businesspeople and some of the stories
they have told us is there's
unquestioning with discrimination
against women
it does happen with there are situations
in which women are paid less not only
for the same work but actually for jobs
that they do better than the men who are
there competing against and when that
happens it is illegal and tribunals in
Shu right so not always that's been from
what amazin told for the most part when
you have but no but also nobody is
suggesting Ivan certainly never
suggested that there isn't
discrimination against women in the
workplace in fact the point is made
explicitly in the video I've never
suggested that well I'm not saying you
have suggest what I'm actually saying is
that that has been the smear that's been
used against the whole video which
actually tries to make some factual
points about the causes of the gender if
you want to boil down the the main point
of the video is actually about media
it's actually sat on the media the Sky
News survey that found that 70 percent
of people in this country believe that
women and men are routinely paid
differently for the same work now that
is factually incorrect and it wouldn't
be a story if it was just a few people
but at the fact that it's 70 percent of
people know that suggests that the media
is misrepresenting this and they are
misrepresenting this the headlines in
all of these stories that Tom and I came
across while we were working on this
it's always on men at HSBC paid more
than women etc men at Ryanair paid more
than women and then the articles
themselves would explain why would
explain the fact that there are more men
in in higher-paying there were more male
pilots that and there are more female
stewards for instance in in the case of
Ryanair and the person who flies the
plane generally gets paid more than the
person who makes the tea right now that
happens then you have another debate
about well why is that the case right
but that's a different debate why is it
that women attention to make different
choices or why is it that women tend to
end up in different jobs right and there
doubtless there's an element of
discrimination involved there there's an
element there's all sorts of possible
variables going on there the video does
not make a distinction about that the
video actually says that fine let's have
that debate let's have that debate that
wasn't what we were talking about we
were talking about the fundamental
misunderstanding about the the media's
deliberate conflation of equal pay and a
gender pay gap that's what we were
saying which is actually true no one's
been able to refute it yet people keep
sending me articles which just back up
my point and they think that they're
refuting it but they're backing up my
point so I don't think I think it's a
misunderstanding
what the video is is saying I'm all for
having debates about structural
imbalance is it you know are there sort
of these sort I I'm very skeptical about
it
because I've studied post structuralism
and I think it's a very reductive view
of the world and I think what we're
seeing at the moment is a kind of
watered down half understood version of
this Foucault daeun idea of power
networks that sort of infest society and
I'm very skeptical about it and I don't
think I think power explains some things
but it doesn't explain everything and it
certainly doesn't explain most things I
think it's so the problem with the
current ideology is everything is to do
with power so first we work out with
your female male whether you're what
race you are what sexuality you are then
we try and put you on a kind of grid to
see where you fit in in the power
structure and that's how we can we
forget about class forget about money
and opportunity get rid of that for the
month and all of these things are
intersecting ok and then we kind of work
out where you are and that explains
everything like every ideology which is
a simplification of the world
that's why anyone who subscribes to an
ideology wholeheartedly is failing
because it is a it is inherently
simplifying oversimplifying very complex
ideas when you try to explain everything
away because of power structures these
nebulous power structures that we can't
pin down that is not a convincing stance
in my view because it it must ignore all
kinds of factors so that's what we sort
of get so actually we were trying to
open up a debate we were saying we can
all agree and we can all agree I think
that it is illegal to pay men and women
differently for the same work but that
is a fact so let's just start by that at
that point and then we discuss why why
people that end up in different roles
that's a different debate we didn't have
that debate but people attacked us as
though we were saying there's no such
thing as sexism there's no such thing as
discrimination we don't need to talk
about it anymore right that's that seem
to be the criticism which is a
fundamental misunderstanding of what the
video did and again what it shows is
that people are just so polarized that
all they can do is simplify oversimplify
their opponents view and then attack a
strawman argument just attack something
that attack a point that neither Tom nor
I were saying right do you think a lot
of the reason that
people get so upset it's because they
don't like you said they don't engage
with the point you were trying to make
because that takes time yeah really I
mean I'm average in terms of
intelligence but in order for me to
really understand an argument I have to
read something three or four times yeah
I have to go away and I have to think
about it and I have to mull it over in
my head you know whereas it's much
easier to go and read something to then
have an emotional response to it and
then do a rebuttal and have 40 seconds
whatever it is or a minute and actually
it takes real time for something to be
able to truly understand something
that's why we do the show is because
we're trying to get to the bottom of
some of these issues you can't have a
debate in hundred ninety like so so
absolutely that's right partly it is
people don't know enough they they often
some of the debates I've seen about this
video people literally do not know what
they are talking about
I don't you a lot of them haven't seen
the video well there's that possibly I
don't know that's been my experience
with a lot of these discussions people a
lot of people argue about stuff they
haven't actually watch that's that's
that's almost certainly the case but I'm
willing to accept that I you know
come with me come at me with the facts
and let's talk about the facts and maybe
I'm wrong and then if you present facts
that prove I'm wrong so be it I accept
that
but but that's but yes you're right it's
a it's an oversimplified form of
argument and that that is a pretty hard
isn't it talk about the gender wage gap
I mean I wouldn't get involved in it
because I don't know enough about it
right I'm not I mean I read like the
garden I read The Times pretty much
every day but I wouldn't say that I'm an
expert on it it's surely not enough to
then go and spout my opinion all over
the internet but also you wouldn't
assume that someone who's raising an
objection is inherently evil for doing
so sorry Anjali thing for me I wanted to
ask you about this video as well was
that one of the main arguments that I
saw being made about it was that here
were two men who'd got a woman spout
their misogynistic opinion before them
yeah and one of the interesting things
that I point out um have you considered
the possible
maybe she agrees with what she's saying
I mean I don't know if actress that you
had agrees or not but yeah and that was
the argument that I saw popping up
probably more than anything but I mean
it's very patronizing isn't it to assume
that a woman who did an acting job
didn't consent to what they were doing I
mean it's it's it it's a bizarre thing
to me and also again I mean this goes
back to what we were saying about
identity politics well if you if you're
saying that this argument is invalid
because it was two men who wrote the
script what happens when I can introduce
you as I can
two women who have a similar feelings to
the character I could introduce you to a
number well we know that certain lies
misogyny right yeah oh it's internalized
myself which again is a point that we
recognized in the in the video and
because she dismisses that as
patronizing bollocks exactly it's it's
it's another strategy to avoid the
argument right so I call you all right I
say you were suffering from internalized
misogyny therefore I don't have to talk
to you I don't have to bother engaging
with the argument that it's a strategy
it's not good enough so yeah you're
right I heard that again and again and
again it's the floor of identity
politics in its current form is that it
can't see beyond the person to the point
it can only focus on that and it's a
it's it's why anyone who peddles those
kind of politics can never win an
argument they can think they weren't it
but they didn't win it and also no one
is persuaded that way no one so where do
we got what I mean we've got a couple of
minutes left where do we go from here it
sounds pretty bad right we're in a
pretty difficult situation I think
education is the key I really do I think
we need to reinstate critical thinking
at the heart of the National Curriculum
I think kids need to be taught that
insulting someone or resorting to ad
hominem attacks means you lose the
assumption that people are wicked
because they don't think the way that
you do we have to rid ourselves as that
the thing is happening right now
right happening now I don't know but but
I I know what I want to happen but I
don't know how to make it happen we need
to stop the polarization we need to stop
that somehow I mean if you say we've
gotten to the kind of camps into tribes
haven't we
so for instance if somebody tells you
their position on abortion I bear
nine
9% of the time you could guess what
their position on every other political
point is right similarly with brexit
right people don't like me claiming to
be on the left because I voted leave for
instance and they don't they can't
reconcile their for me on a personal
level I can't reconcile voting for a
right-wing corporate body to be anything
other than a right-wing thing to do so I
can't reconcile being on the left with
voting in favor with the EU I can't so
but that's my mus my views a separate
issue but the point is that the
assumption is made okay I write for
spiked okay alright yeah you know I
voted leave okay right wing right you're
completely wrong about this but it
doesn't matter because you're simplified
worldview you can only you can only deal
in confirmation bias
you can only deal in your own
assumptions being played out and
therefore you don't bother addressing
the your opponent properly and in an
adult manner that that is a problem but
I think if I were to suggest a solution
which I I don't know I think after Trump
for instance after after Trump happened
I was convinced and it's part of the
reason we wrote the video I was
convinced that the left would try and
get his house in order but actually
what's happened is everyone's just
doubling down on all the same stuff and
making it worse and worse and worse and
pushing this form of identity politics
which is pernicious and divisive and we
need to somehow find a way I think it
comes from criticism within its own
ranks it has to be people on the left
that address this stuff for instance
just to make this point cuz I think is
an important one the the question of
free speech should be the heart of
anything of anything left alright it
transcends left and right but because
the Left have continually eroded free
speech or allowed it to be eroded and in
some cases pushed for it for it to be
resisted what you find is when people
mention free speech you assume it's a
right-wing person when I set up this
free speech comedy night and what we
really mean by that is that you don't
self sense or we couraging people not to
self-censor
the Sunday Telegraph wrote an article
saying thank god we've got a right-wing
comedy night it's run by two lefties we
do have some right-wing people very few
because you couldn't fill it a bill we
have we have had a few riping people's
we want we want we want people more
breath that's the point but actually so
far it has been mostly people on the
left to in truth but that assumption
tells us a lot that the connection of
free speech because what happened is the
left
created a vacuum around this issue they
stopped defending the principle and then
the right swooped in and now you've got
people like Tommy Robinson Katie Hopkins
God you've got these people defending
and they're they're right on the
principle this is the this is the
problem the reason why so many people in
committees don't want to defend count
down killer is because he's associated
with Tommy Robertson the reason that
Association exists is because subsequent
to the trial remember that it doesn't
predate the trial
Tommy Robinson came in to defend him
right so now we can't defend him because
it's been the mantles been seized by the
right what's going on there no we have
to be able to say actually this
principle is bigger than Robinson it's
bigger than anyone
it's bigger than left and right and it's
a it's the I'm so frustrated I'm more
frustrated with the failings of the left
than I am of the right because I'm from
the left I know what the findings of the
right are and people often criticize me
as when want you slagging off the right
all the time because it's a given to me
I know where they're going wrong and and
I think I think if we are going to get
out of this quagmire it has to be the
left that put its own house in order and
the first step on that is ridding
ourselves of this form of identity
politics because we're dividing everyone
up and we're creating a lot of
resentment and we are not convincing
anyone you know if you just block
everyone on Twitter who who has a
different opinion than you well are you
really serious about your convictions
then because you're obviously not
prepared to attempt to persuade anyone
fantastic stuff so before you go thank
you very much Andrew I think absolutely
brilliant is there anything that you
would like to plug whether it's your
Twitter handle whether it's fight
whatever it is oh well I don't know I'm
on Twitter
Andrew Doyle underscore calm so if you
want to send abuse I will yeah what's
your comedy and I called and whereas
it's called comedy Unleashed and it's
every month at the backyard comedy club
in Bethnal Green and it's the second
Tuesday of every month and we've got
some great lineups got Bobbie mayor is
doing the next one we've got Shazia
Mercer Jonathan PI is gonna come and do
one and Jeff and all cop some very
fantastic acts so yeah do do come along
to that I've got a show on at the Soho
Theatre in July can i plug that yes
you're plugging it right now the gets
caught crimes
what's that about
just a random title I just chose no it's
a it's it's it's about it's so sure I
didn't anybody and it's a lot of it is
rooted in the idea of all the friends I
lost over brexit because of people's it
just what I'm willingness to debate or
you know and and just to make assumption
so it's it's it sounds very worthy and
actually because this has been such a
non comedic discussion I would like to
emphasize that when I write comedy it's
quite funny when I talk off stage it's
not yeah thank you very much for coming
along I'm Constance in kitchen you can
find me on Twitter ad Constance and
kitchen I'm failing human semi abuses
mostly people just do it subscribe to
our YouTube channel follow us in the
iTunes and do whatever is - yes
absolutely please give us a rating on
iTunes download it follow us at trigger
pod whether it's Twitter or Instagram
and thank you very much for tuning in
have a lovely week
you